- yup GERD I have GERD gastroesophageal
reflux disease me to GERD boys girl boys
in the house where did that come from
because I've had girls you feel out if
you've Gert I have girl I took this
medication for GERD and then when I take
it you know what my side effect is can't
sneeze I thought my forehead was gonna
blow up and I was like and I would just
go choo choo choo nothing came out that
day but one day I forgot my garden
medicine I sneezed at dude this
that was coming out of my nose was wild
wow you got nose constipated absolutely
hey what's up everybody welcome to
stupid questions I'm Krista Stefano
tonight's guest map - Broussard you can
follow him on Twitter at Monday pun day
and he's got an album out called panned
antic pedantic pedantic philosopher dad
it's pronounced pedantic that word means
Chris no means ostentatious or showy um
one's knowledge well don't I feel like a
pandan dick and he showed me a pun is
actually can we just do it yeah okay so
Matthew Broussard just follow matt
monday pun day I was just with him in
Vegas and I was trying to have a good
time and he was just making me guests
puns okay so this is a man I see Tiger
Woods Tiger Woods with a dragon uh-huh
what's the dragon doing the dragon is
creeping leaning bending down what am i
doing creeping around he's looking over
looking dragons on my shoulder you want
you to see him no no he's hiding yeah
hiding so Tiger hide a tiger in hiding
no no no I love that you believe that is
the Tiger Hidden Dragon
all right next to the question what he
thinks
everybody looks stupid doing using the
elliptical machine yeah that's dumb yeah
that's dumb that's not real
what is that simulate looks like you're
cross-country skiing over moguls yeah do
the elliptical no no no get on the
Stairmaster
but you exercise a lot yeah yeah you
drift I saw you in Vegas and you kept
being like let's go to the pool and I'm
like I don't want to go to the pool with
you do you understand that I have fluffy
fat nipples and you're just built like a
guy but the work you do up back here
yeah yeah yeah yeah upper and lower now
people like you're not really Jewish I'm
like you should check out my back hair
you what newer it's all haha that's what
I that's what I like there's always
balance in the world no handsome guy
you're ripped and then when you turn
there I was like ah there it is he's got
back acne was gross but yeah alright
next super question does it ever make
you upset that you look like the state
of Connecticut if it became a person no
well you look like if I like if I was
able to like press a button and make my
khakis into a person it's you it's the
nicest thing anyone's ever said could
you boy what do you what are you though
I guess like a mozzarella stick if they
could talk or like I don't know if I
guess you it is you're a UFC t-shirt was
a person thank you so much for doing the
show I'd like to give you a stupid gift
now now you know I know you were a
swimmer and even if you weren't a
swimmer you you are the definition of
STF swim team face so I wanted to give
you a swim cap oh I don't know if it
fits your head or no if it's one size
fits all I just figured though it's if
it's made for a swimmers head you have a
swimmer set bro dude look at that yes
yes thank you for diving in to stupid
questions with Chris de Stefano
this is Matthew Broussard find him on on
Twitter and Instagram Monday pun day and
he's got his album pond antic is that
right I can't hear you okay well I think
it's pond antics elves like that go in
my hair it didn't really how do you take
off that swim cap on your hair is still
perfect Wow
I want to punch you and also kiss you
you